[Music]
hi welcome to our session on what's new
and Android development tools I'm Jamal
a product manager on the Android CTO
team and lets me out toward the injuring
director on Cydia as well we are excited
to share some of the latest updates to
Android studio we strive to make your
lives easier by delivering a high
quality IDE that works at the latest
Android AP is and Android features on
top of that we'd love to hear your
feedback to make sure we're working on
things that matter to you than most
today we're gonna talk about a range of
things from the latest stable to some
bleeding edge features okay
let's get started with a quick update
roadmap of where we've been an i/o last
year we launched Android studio 3.2
which had support for app bundle
navigation editor and emulator snapshots
in a new energy profile allows you to
understand how your app impacts the
battery on a device earlier this year we
launched Android studio 3.3 and this
included in product feedback and single
variant sync which improves the speeds
of sync speeds in the IDE and just a few
days ago we launched Android studio 3.4
which included a new resource manager an
updated project structure dialog box and
a shift to our 8 as a default app
shrinker and in case you missing these
updates stay tuned for a demo at the end
of the session for these acts these
features in action and lastly that
brings us to studio 3.5 so to walk us
through what's inside of Android studio
3.5 I'll give over the tour to walk us
through it all right morning everyone
so most years I get to stand in front of
you and play Santa Claus and give a 25
minute demo of all the cool new features
and surprises the team has built over
the last year this year is gonna be a
bit different I don't have any new
features to show you and that's because
we've been busy addressing your top
complaints so what I'm gonna do today is
tell you what we did and I think as
engineers you
interesting but I'm hoping that as users
you'll be really excited maybe even as
excited as official the new feature
because you'll see how your daily usage
of the IDE will improve so right great
so to set the context we announced
project marble back in November and
since then the entire engineering team
has been focusing exclusively on fixing
top issues that impact users so we can
divide that work into three buckets
system health feature polish and
addressing the bug backlog so let's
start with system health so by that I
mean how responsive is the UI or are
there any memory leaks so the first
thing we did was to beef up our
analytics the first time you run Android
studio we ask you if you're willing to
send use of statistics to us now as
you'll see this is how we measure our
system health it's how we're measuring
whether project marble is having an
impact and it's also how we're gonna
basically make sure that after project
marble ends we're gonna hold the bar
really high and last but not least we
used analytics to report problems to
ourselves so for example if Andra studio
throws an exception if you've opted into
analytics we will send that exception up
to our server and then we have a
dashboard where we can aggregate all
these exceptions sort them such that we
not only fix the most important issues
but we can also spot if there's a
problem in a rollout of a new canary so
another issue with exceptions let's say
you're in your editor coding away having
a good time and suddenly there's this
little blinky light in the bottom right
corner drawing your attention away if
you've been using an der studio I'm sure
you've encountered this well because of
our automated crash reporting we don't
actually need to distract you from your
coding tasks to send that report to us
we already have it so from now on we no
longer do these are just silently logged
except for one class of problems right
and those are foreground actions
so as an example let's say that a
toolbar action is broken if you were
clicking on it and clicking and nothing
was happening you'd be very frustrated
right so foreground actions we continue
to show but we no longer blink so the
exceptions should be much less demanding
a retention from now on UI freezes is
another top concern for us and by that I
mean something like the spinning beach
ball on the map right so this happens
when the UI thread is busy waiting on a
slow call so to find these what we're
doing is if the UI thread is not
responding for a few seconds again we
will grab a whole thread dump and upload
it to our server and then we can put in
this dashboard so here's an example when
I grab this the top freeze was on
average 14 seconds long and we have over
50,000 reports of that right so what we
could do now is to multiply those two
numbers together sort them and then we
can prioritize which UI freezes are
causing the most total wait time for our
usage population so here's the little
animation of one of our fixes this is
editing an XML file with data binding
this used to be extremely slow and we
fix that among with many other freezes
and we're not just spot fixing the UI
freezes we are doing a lot of work to
prevent regressions in this area so here
are two examples first of all we
modified Android lint to run on Android
Studios code base which you know is not
an Android app and so we have static
analysis which looks for common causes
of freezes we also built a JVM agent
which we are including in our UI test
Suites
so whenever the UI thread is accessing a
network Hall we fail the test this is a
bit like strict mode in Android next
let's talk about memory problems and by
now you can probably spot a trend we
have a dashboard so whenever the IDE
runs out of memory we grab some
statistics about the heap and send it to
our server and there are two reasons why
you can run out of memory the first one
is that studio requires a lot of it we
model all your code all your resources
and so if you have a massive project it
might not fit but what if you have 32
gigabytes of RAM that should be enough
right well it turns out that when studio
runs on the JVM its heap size is limited
to 1.2 gigabytes it does not
automatically resize itself that's just
not how the JVM works so even on a 32
gigabyte system studio only gets to use
a tiny fraction of that ram now why did
we pick 1.2 we were afraid to make it
bigger because in that case studio won't
even start on a low-end machine and
we're afraid to make it smaller because
well then you can't even load a regular
size project so a pro tip is that you
can actually change the size of the heap
to give studio more memory where it'll
run faster but again we know from
analytics that almost none of you do 99%
of our users are running with 1.2
gigabyte heat size so that's why in 3 5
we look at your available ram as well as
the project size and we make specific
recommendations and you can just click
on the save and restore action here to
accept our suggestion or you can open up
the new memory settings dialog where you
can tweak to your heart's content you
can also set the heap sizes for the
Gradle demon and the Kotlin daemon as
well and of course we base these
recommendations again on data from
analytics we've created a model where we
are doing some correlation between the
heap size and the file count and the
module count and things like that but
what if there's a memory leak in that
case no heap size will ever be big
enough it will run out of memory
eventually so it's been a top priority
to fix that but the dashboard only has
high-level statistics when someone runs
out of memory how do we actually track
down the culprit and we built a really
cool mechanism for that so if we can
look at your heap we can find the leaks
but obviously we're not going to ask you
to send your whole heaps to us because
they're massive and B they contain a lot
of personal information think about it
your source editor has all of your
source has some of your source files in
it that's in the heap right so we don't
want the heat so what we do instead is
if studio runs out of memory or is
nearly running out of memory and it's
not functional anymore well then we grab
a heap dump and we store it on your
machine then next time you start studio
we optionally run an analysis on that
heat file we generate a report and then
we delete the heat file and so the
report file does not have anything
personal in it it's just a plain text
file which lists likely leaks that we've
found now you can scroll through the
whole thing and convince yourself
there's nothing personal there and
hopefully you'll click the send button
at the end to upload it to our servers
and so we shipped this facility in 3-5
canary and it's been incredibly valuable
we have found tons of leaks that way
that we have fixed and actually the
first couple of leaked reports we got
had a big leak from a popular
third-party plugin and so we grabbed the
details and we sent it as a bug report
to that plugin developer and they let us
know that they had heard about this leak
for years but had never tracked it down
but armed with our bug report they fixed
it within 24 hours
so having Clyde side leak analysis is
incredibly valuable because it doesn't
just find leaks in our code that we test
and ship it finds it in all the plugins
you're using so it brings the whole
plug-in ecosystem forward but so while
reacting to leak reports is great it's
not awesome because that means that
we've already shipped a leak and
negatively affected many of you so
another thing we've done recently which
is really promising is we've implemented
a new test runner this runs our test in
a special way iteratively and it grabs
heap snapshots between each run and then
it does some comparisons and it can
automatically find leaks so this
recently caught a massive memory leak
this is a real screen shot from our
build server it found this leak
automatically and it was a really tricky
leak so this would have
if we haven't had this but thankfully
was caught before a chip the last system
health after bait I'll talk about is
speed so one sort of well-known secret
to a better idea formance is to disable
plugins you're not using and that's not
a bad idea to begin with because it
reduces UI clutter if there's a version
control system you're not using why
should it be in your version control
menu but you shouldn't have to do this
for performance so one particular
problem area we found was the C++
plug-in in some cases it would be doing
work even in a non C++ project so we've
what we did there was we added a bunch
of fast exits if we can tell there's no
C++ in the project and that's been very
effective of course the number one speed
complaint we always get for an der
studio is the build system and it has
always been a top priority for us even
back in the Eclipse days and I'm
confident that next year it'll still be
our top priority so because of that we
obviously didn't stop working on build
speed during project marble and in fact
we have several big improvements we made
annotation processing count line
incremental we made six out of the top
ten used Android annotation processors
incremental there's actually a lot to
cover on the build system so I'm not
gonna spend time on it here instead we
have a whole separate talk later today
it's called what's new in the Android
build system it's a great talk you
definitely don't want to miss it
a majority of our users are actually on
Windows and it turns out that there's a
lot of unique issues on Windows with
things like you know the file separator
character we recently fixed long path
support but performance is a particular
concern and the biggest impact by far is
the virus checker file rights are
multiple times slower when a folder is
being checked with the virus checker so
in our measurements if you exclude the
studio and SDK folders and your project
folders some of these common operations
you see here are four times faster in
our measurements and basically
comparable to Linux performance so what
we're doing now is on startup
we have this new info card which lets
you know if your SDK folder and your
project folder are not excluded by the
virus checker now this does not mean
that you should go and blindly exclude
these folders you are running a virus
checker for a reason and you have to
decide the right trade-off between
performance and security and you need to
take extra precautions if you do exclude
folders from the virus checker but we
hope that at least this notification
will make your users I'm sorry who fake
affected users aware of this issue and
this opportunity and finally on CPU
usage the emulator we got a lot of
complaints that the emulator was
spending a lot of CPU cycles when it's
supposed to be idle so you're in the
editor emulators off to the side
yep somehow your fans are running so we
fixed many issues in this area and I
want to highlight two that I just found
super interesting so the first one is
that yes indeed when you're using the
Play image it was really busy because it
turns out Google Play services is
running after startup and it is busy
updating things and optimizing apps and
of course that was burning cycles now
how do we fix that because what we don't
want is for the emulator to behave is
for the system image to behave
differently in the emulator versus on a
real phone so the team found a cool fix
they basically tell the system image
you're on battery when the system image
is on battery it turns off most
background services so that was a neat
fix but that made the screen saver kick
in more often and turn off the display
so we had to fix that as well a second
cool fix is that the system image was
listening for the hot word right so on a
phone you can say okay I'm not gonna say
the next word but it turns out that
actually worked in the emulator and
there's no hardware support for
listening to the hot word there so the
the CPU was busy listening for the hot
word that was expensive and it's I think
it's kind of cool that it worked but
that was not on purpose
so you know we fixed this by turning off
the microphone by default if your app
needs it you could turn it back on so a
big part of project marble was fixing
system health
the second area we work on was fixing
features that aren't working so well so
we're calling that polish on this slide
but that might give you the wrong
impression this wasn't just you know
getting out a little cloth and wiping
off a smudge this was fixing some dents
sanding in some cases replacing whole
parts and I think the best example of
that is instant run so we have a new
version of instant run
it's called apply changes and from the
outside it looks like the same feature
it's fast incremental run you can
hot-swap your a code and resources into
running out but this is a complete
rewrite from the ground up we deleted 50
thousand lines of code from instant run
I guess boo instant run here so we've
also limited it to work for Android Oreo
and above and that led us remove a bunch
of hacks that we have added that we had
added an instant run to work on dalvik
and older API levels so now we're only
using supported platform api's to do
things like a bit resources and to
hot-swap code so before we would rewrite
all your bytecode up front we would you
know have to insert hooks into your byte
code to allow for later hot swapping so
that made clean builds much slower if
you got instant run on and worse it
would actually spend some of the method
handles you have a budget of 64,000
method handles 65,000 method handles and
so some users would turn on instant run
and they couldn't build anymore well
that is not an issue at all anymore with
apply changes there's no cost
we don't modify your app in any way the
apk we push to the device is identical
to what you would do without apply
changes and so now we use hot swap
basically from the platform
instrumentation another reason why apply
changes is better is that it is
stateless we are no longer keeping track
of what the build system has done so far
and that led to all kinds of trouble
when you would do things on the local
device such as plugging in different
devices so apply changes is much more
robust we fixed many things so broking
in broken in instant run such as
multiprocessor
apps so definitely give it a shot but
best of all many of the things that the
team did for apply changes actually
benefits all runs there were big
improvements to the deployment pipeline
around signing and app installs another
feature we reworked is Gradle sync so
while we've made it faster with
something called single variant sync our
main focus was making it more reliable
things like the indexing suspender had
all kinds of issues that should be
better now in 3-5 beta we also tried to
make fail sync more actionable the error
message should be clearer we should have
more suggestions and if you've been
using studio you might have seen
something like this screenshot right
with the editor shows up with red
symbols there are several root causes
for this problem but I want to highlight
one kind of fun one so when you build
with Gradle it will cache all jar files
that you have referenced in your
projects under your home directory all
jar files you've ever referenced so this
is a cache that gets bigger and bigger
and bigger and so last year Gradle
introduced a really great new feature
where they do automatic cleanup of your
cache so if a library hasn't been
touched by Gradle in between seven and
thirty days it'll be automatically
cleaned up which is nice but in studio
when you restart the IDE for performance
reasons we don't actually do a real
Gradle build we typically just load a
cached sync stage from last time so we
would load a cached state pointing to
libraries in your Gradle folder which
had since been cleaned up so we didn't
have tests for this we didn't realize
the implication of this new feature but
now we do and it's been fixed along with
many other issues yay right so
so speaking of dependencies when we
switched to Gradle we made dependency
management really easy all you have to
say is you know I depend on recycle if
you give it to me and the build system
will download it for you and as we've
just seen cleaned it up eventually but
for some of you this has created a big
problem you can't really bring your
project on a USB stick anymore you'll
have your sources but not your libraries
so if you're trying to bring your
project to disconnected computer it just
can't
it doesn't work and there were other
users who had problems with strict
internet proxies you know at their work
site and some of you might be
temporarily but out of network because
you're flying to Google i/o so in three
five we are trying to make this better
we're working on making all of our
repositories downloadable so in 3-5 beta
you can download our Gradle plugin with
all of its recursive dependencies you
can also download maven at Google calm
all the stable versions and what you do
then is you unzip these folders under
your home directory and then you drop
this script into the Gradle init folder
don't take notes this is in the readme
for each one of these downloadable
repositories but the point is when this
script is there you don't have to modify
any of your project on the machine you
build and if the if these dependencies
are in your offline cache offline
folders it'll just work so this is super
helpful if like Google your company has
a policy where you don't want your build
servers to be hitting the internet
downloading stuff right
we check in pre builds for all of our
dependencies and now with you can easily
do the same we're also trying to improve
project upgrades so if you created a
project in 3 1 and you open it in 3 3
you'd get a scary looking warning like
this one saying that you have to fix
your dependencies or your project will
break soon well this message is gone we
always want sync to succeed and we will
give you build advice later where we
give you advice for your code right so
inspections editor underlines and the
product structure dialogue and for this
specific example we have a lint check
and
fix to handle it data binding so data
binding was always say supported feature
and I'm gonna put that in quotes because
it was riddled with problems so you've
already seen the animation earlier of
the performance problems but we also
went and fix the cluster of bugs and we
even added some feature ish things to
make things better so we added some new
lint checks to pinpoint common
configuration problems we added some
code folding to make it easier to work
with so if you've been using data
binding please switch to 3/5 it's gonna
be better I promise
so our focus in project marble was on
the first two areas I've already
outlined system health and fixing broken
features but we also assign engineers to
work on some top priority bugs and some
top voted bugs so when I pulled the
stats a few weeks ago we had fixed over
400 bugs and you know this is beta so I
think by the time we hit stable meaning
the numbers gonna be even higher and
that's not all right so due to time
constraints I can't actually cover
everything we've done for project marble
so I'll just list quickly a few more in
the layout editor we fixed a bunch of
usability problems in the build output
window we worked on our error parsers
and the UI to make it do a much better
job pinpointing what the build problem
is and why the build failed the 3/5
download is actually 300 megabytes
smaller than 3/4 we work to make lint CI
faster and so on so to sum up project
marble was a really large investment for
us we dug into your top complaints and I
hope that you'll notice a big
improvement when you switch to 3/5 and
the last thing I want to say is that we
do know that we are not done we have not
reached inbox zero for our bug tracker
not even close but we built a lot of
infrastructure to catch problems and we
built these dashboards where we can
monitor the health of Studio out in the
field if you please opt into analytics
so that one so that when we start
landing features again will hopefully
hold the bar high and with
I'm gonna turn it back over to Jamal
thanks to her so as you can tell we put
a ton of work into project marble and we
encourage you to update to Android
studio 3.5 beta today to take advantage
of all these updates from project marble
now speaking of updates we recently did
a survey with many of you about the
upgrade process and from the day that we
found that a lot of people update
Android studio and Gradle at the same
time now this was required a couple
years ago for features like instant run
but as of today can actually upgrade
your Gradle plugin and studio separately
and as you heard from tor we're making
great strides at making the project
upgrade experience easier but we
understand it takes a little little
extra time to upgrade your Gradle files
so from an IDE perspective you should
always run the latest version of Android
studio and you can upgrade your project
reader files when you are ready just
like choosing your Android X version
keeping Gradle up to date gives you new
features performance improvements and
correctness benefits but we give you the
choice with this version flexibility
this allows you and your team to use any
version of Android studio stable beta
canary and as long as you're using the
same version of a stable Gradle plug-in
you have the flexibility okay so far we
talked about a number of updates from
stable to project marble and you heard
that our focus is on project marble and
quality however I'm now gonna give you a
sneak peek of a few projects we started
before project marble they're gonna get
back to later on this year okay let's
switch over to the demo
okay
so let's say we wanted to do some
last-minute validation in checks on the
Google i/o app so like many of your apps
these apps could be quite complex you
can have a ton of resources a ton of
Java and cotton files many times it's
hard to understand what's going on here
without really digging into the source
code so one way you can validate this is
just to run the app so this case I have
the i/o app here running on the Android
emulator the first thing I want to check
is floatable support so with Android
studio 2.5 we now allow you to create a
photo boleyn of your app so things look
pretty good looks like we have four
columns of content that looks pretty
good on this instance and here in the
tool bar we have this new icon called
fold I'll fold it up and then we get the
new context of the new app so things
look pretty good here on the Android
emulator for for affordable the next
thing I want to check out is dark theme
so as you know Android cue has an
operating system level support for dark
theme we can also control it in your app
as well so for the Google i/o app I can
go to the menu go to settings here and
we have this new Chiefs theme option so
what I'm looking for specifically it's
making sure I have that nice blue accent
color and both dark and light theme you
choose theme here and they go to dark ah
look there's some issue right looks like
these switches are red and that's not
what I want so to help diagnose this in
a future version of Android studio we're
gonna help you have a new version of the
layout inspector so if you're not
familiar with the layout inspector is a
way for you to look at the hierarchy of
your app and see what's going on
so in left-hand side has a view tree
hierarchy tree and then I'm right
right-hand side has a nice set of
properties that you can cook that you
can click on so in our case you know
we're looking at a number 10 attributes
we added to the two new features to this
layout inspector number one if you had
some issues with elevation where this
cool new feature that allows you to look
at the various levels of replication
which is pretty cool
in our case it looks like we're really
going to focus on an issue and the
actual switch colors so me just an
update those up here okay and let me
click on this switch and what's
different about this is that it looks
like there's some issue here with my
switch material okay and here's a
property for this so what's different
about this layout spectre-4 with this d1
is i can go from this layouts vector
directly to the source code so let's
show that let me show you that so me
hide this panel here hide it's highly at
the attribute I just press command B and
boom right here in locked on the left
hand side is now the source code that
defined this attribute now as you saw in
that and that example there was an issue
with a theme so we go to the styling and
do another control B command B again and
go over to the styles and looks like me
up two pins to burn styles one that's a
regular one and one that's a night one
let me go to the night one here alright
and I see here's the issue it looks like
someone had left it to do to check on
accessibility colors so let me just
comment those out real quick and see if
that fixes the problem for me so what
I'm going to do here is click on the
apply changes button
so as tor mentioned to you earlier this
is a quick way to get quick fixes to the
device without doing a full build on the
on the device okay so back to the
emulator it's running red it's blue and
it's fixed that fixes the problem for us
and then the validate on a layout
Specter let me just refresh the layout
inspector and boom everything's good
so that is layout inspection alright the
next thing to talk about is around
resources so and I know for many of you
you have a lot of a lot of resources in
your app projects and the problem today
is that if you want to understand what
these assets are get that double-click
on all of these assets which is not that
great so we added in Android studio 3.4
is a new resource manager so by the
module type actually now I can see
visualizations of all the different
assets both in a list view and a grid
view and see how they all work and
and of course if you had a MIT map for
instance I can look at the MIT map drill
into the assets and see all the various
densities of my application so one other
pain point we're addressing is that many
times you have a design team giving you
updates to your application me times
let's say a bulk file of SDG files so in
the past would have to individually
update each s e-g file and convert them
to a vector drawable you solved that
problem so now if you click this plus
button here and go to import drawables
and here I have a folder of s s e-g
assets let me come to this parent folder
and we just let the folder here and
import this entire folder and boom and
here we have this asset wizard allows
you to import all these assets and as
does a couple different things it checks
for syntax of all the file assets so for
example here it looks like we have the
extra import asset here so this one has
an extra input import so we can actually
move this one and it looks we can also
have a syntax error here so connection
with this from a uppercase G to
lowercase G I press the import and boom
here all the assets convert it from
vector drop from SVG / - back to draw 1
1 click
now another great thing about this is
the panel is actually pretty interactive
so actually you can I can drag and drop
these assets onto any arbitrary XML file
and see it visualized here as well now
let's say if you actually want to want
to edit these files in XML no problem
all I got to do is go back to the XML
view of this application go back to my
assets I can highlight the asset move it
right over to the XML attribute I want
to update drop it on there it updates
that and there's the asset updated the
asset updated in real time there we go
alright the last I talked about in in
this version is an update to the project
structure dialog box so this is sort
people who do not like editing Grado
files so what you can see here is a list
of all your dependencies and modules and
what's pretty cool about this is I can
click on all different modules see all
resolve dependencies and find any
conflicts and lastly we have a
suggestions panel so if there's any sort
of updates or any kind of insert
conflicts we have it all consolidated
into one view and so it's a few clicks I
can update my Gradle file without ever
having to update and manually edit my
build our Gradle file so pretty cool
so next I want to talk about is motion
layout so motion layout is actually
reaching beta status say this week but
motion and elet layout is a pretty cool
feature if you have not used it
basically it builds on top of constraint
layout in motion layout allows you to
have motion and move elements on the
screen and it contains two components
one you have this motion layout file
that describes how all the elements are
described in a layout the next style you
have is called a scene file and the
scene file describes how all the
elements move across the screen over
time now it's not too difficult to edit
these files in XML but it's not the
simplest thing so we're working on after
project marble after is a editor for
this so here's my app that I'm working
on and if I can click on one of the
components in the tree here we now open
up a new timeline view and so what's
cool about this is I can see both my
start state my in state but also I can
scrub through all the various states of
animation and play them back and forth
to see how the animations going to work
over time so pretty cool
and so the last thing I'll talk about is
around jetpack Campos so as you heard
yesterday we just launched an ASP an
early access preview of compose and what
this is did what this is doing is
actually kind of combining the best of
kind of reactive programming in Kotlin
so instead of having a separate XML file
and a cullen file we're putting it all
together in here so I'm just gonna walk
you through how this code is structured
so for instance from I'm creating in
this card here on the right hand side I
have all my attributes of my padding I
have my rows I can put the text files
right in here and so all this is
happening all inside one file and inside
of this compose function and of course
you can run this inside the emulator so
we invite you to try this out we have a
special version of Android studio that's
available in the Android Open Source
project that's specifically designed for
this purpose so please check it out
afterwards in your leisure with that
let's go back to slides
all right so I didn't have time to demo
everything but another cool update is on
Chrome OS version 75 on high-end x86
Chromebooks we have official support for
Android studio 3.5 so it's cool about
this update it also includes USB
debugging support and a chrome OS
installer another up to LMS is a new
emulator with support for the embedded
Android automotive alright so we can
talk about everything about Android
studio and project marble today so we
invite you to see a couple other
sessions as well so yesterday there's a
talk of the Android emulator you should
check that out as well this morning that
a check a discussion around design tools
this morning later on have a deep dive
session on the constraint layout and
also the nice tips and tricks session
coming up on and ER studio you should
not miss as well again we are excited to
launch Android studio 3.5 and beta for
you to download today it's the
culmination of all of work inside a
project marble even with the new
infrastructure and Nash works in place
quality is definitely not done but we
hope you enjoy this release which has
less features but it's focused more on
the fundamentals ok that's it thanks for
watching a session on Android dev tools
[Music]